are you both doing great thanks for
asking
Wow do other people walk in and start
like immediately right I can't play that
way so I want to start with I saw the
first two episodes last night I thought
you guys did a great job I think fans of
High School Musical are really gonna dig
this thing but what's crazy is that for
people that don't realize explain like
the sort of meta nature of this show
because it's like the you know what I
mean yeah it is very meta it's very hard
to kind of explain and also to
comprehend but to try to go about in a
good way
it's about a group of students who go to
the school where the original movies
were shot and so their drama teacher
realizes that they've never done a
production of High School Musical at the
school where High School Musical was
shot that's crazy
so she she decides to start auditions
and it's it's crazy because it's it's a
series about a musical that's about a
musical that was a movie and I think
we're just very we know what's happening
yeah which is weird because there's not
a lot of things out there that are like
that yeah
so I think the fact the title is perfect
for it's like we're doing High School
Musical as a musical as a series about
the movies about the same it's it's
great and I yeah oh sorry no you're good
I was just gonna say that it's I mean it
really is an ingenious way to redo High
School Musical owning what it is yeah
you know it's um oh sorry no you're good
good in the show you guys are
auditioning for a musical and in real
life you are auditioning for a musical
for the series so it's even more twisted
talk a little bit about that first
audition or the auditioning process for
the show and you know what you were
feeling yeah my first audition was
actually a self tape because I was in
Utah I'm actually filming a different
series that I was doing and I was like
oh my gosh I'm auditioning for a mean
girl role like I had never done this
before I hope like they liked it like I
just like I wasn't I didn't have a lot
of high hopes for it I really tried my
best but I just didn't know if
could play a mean girl that well and
then they called me back I was going out
to LA when I had a break and now we're
here somehow but it's it's really crazy
yeah I think for me it was an extremely
lengthy process but it was so worth it
uh I think Disney has big shoes to fill
obviously and they know like we know and
I think they've been since the third
movie trying to find a way to reimagine
this and re reduce something like this
all while knowing that the movies were
so iconic and we want to pay respects to
that and even throughout the auditioning
process there was so much that was like
oh this is great but like this might be
too much like the movies and let's tweak
this a little bit let's tweak that a
little bit so they were very nice and
precise yes the thing that's crazy is
before your show is even premiered you
have a season two you know you got
greenlit for another season when did you
find out and what does it mean to you we
found out yesterday actually which was
amazing so we found out like a couple
hours before the world knew um but we
were all freaking out we were screaming
we were crying we were laughing darah
broken nail I lost my voice almost fell
over onto the ground but I think world
is so grateful to be here and and not
only just have a first season of this
incredible series but be able to have
another one totally yeah group texts oh
absolutely we have so many yeah I
understand yeah thanks for inviting me
to that text I gotta go um Congrats on
the show I know people are gonna dig it
hey Jay